sorry talking about that's color okay no
I'm on okay so thank you the organizer
point way to me and thank you everyone
for coming when to talk about sub linear
algorithms for Delta Plus on vertex
coloring this is joint work with my
advisors and I've gone on and on another
student sue graph coloring we all know
the definition just a quick recap I have
a graph I have a palette of let's say
size C colors and I want to choose a
color from this palette for every vertex
such that there are no monochromatic
edges in the graph sample this is my
graph this is a palette of four colors
then I'm going to color it like this no
edge has bought in Sandpoint with the
same color this is a central problem in
graph theory and computer science and it
has tons of different application mainly
to scheduling and symmetry breaking a
special case of this problem is when my
palette has size Delta plus 1 Delta here
is the maximum degree in my graph and
for notation I'm going to use n always
to denote the number of vertices so now
I want to color my graph with Delta plus
1 color
boy this is interesting
one reason is that every graph admits
the Delta plus one color in and this is
the minimal number such that this
statement is true because for cliques
and odd cycles you actually need Delta
plus 1 colors there are other reason one
is that it's this very nice algorithm
property if I give you any partial
coloring of your graph as long as this
part is feasible you can always go ahead
later and extend it to a proper Delta
plus 1 color this is only true for this
Delta plus 1 colors even graphs which
are Delta colorable does not have this
property and such a property is going to
become very helpful in designing
algorithms
finally this problem is related to tons
of other fundamental problems such as
maximal independent set maximal matching
or H coloring with two Delta minus 1
edges filers so we are going to focus on
this problem what do we know about this
problem it's a very simple sequential
algorithm that solve this problem
iterate over your vertices for each
vertex pick one of the colors available
to this vertex meaning that this color
should not appear it's in neighborhood
why does this thing work because if your
maximum degrees Delta and you have Delta
plus 1 colors available to you you will
always find a color to color this vertex
so we have this extremely simple
algorithm that solve this problem and
this is also it's highly efficient
algorithm it requires linear time and a
space in some sense you cannot hope for
anything better but let's say let's just
answer this question can I get even more
efficient algorithms and to answer such
a question we have to look at this realm
of sub linear algorithms so instance of
sub linear algorithms maybe I want to
solve linear time algorithm this means
that I want to solve this problem faster
than even reading my entire input or
maybe a streaming algorithm I'm going to
even do not a store my graph I'm going
to just make it streamed its edges to
you and I want you to use that space
much as smaller than what is needed to a
store this graph and then solve the
problem there is also this massively
parallel computation water it basically
tries to capture the sort of MapReduce
a.style computation where you want to
have a sub linear communication between
the machines in fact for the purpose of
this talk it doesn't really matter what
are the exact definition of these models
we have seen them throughout the talk
see but let's not really worry about
that and I'll tell you why
oh by the way it's a workshop on
something algorithms I don't think I
need to motivate something algorithms
they're good so now the question is that
can be designs of linear algorithms or
Delta plus one color in no this is the
time I'm giving you this probe talk
course of linear algorithms that
probably not really why well one reason
is that if I look at similar problems to
this Delta plus 1 colors this is
probably impossible to do these things
for maximal independence we prove in the
same paper that there is no sub linear
space as streaming algorithm and for
maximal matching we prove that there is
no sub linear time algorithm these are
somewhat as straightforward result but
they are non-trivial is still to proof
so in something it says that if I look
at the problems in this family they are
hard so maybe Delta Plus on coloring
design is this informal reasons that
basically in sub linear algorithms which
usually need some extra room to work
with exact problems tends to be hard so
we need to allow for some sort of
approximation most meaningful perhaps
approximation here is to let me give you
some extra more colors maybe Delta plus
some constant times Delta more colors or
order that other okay so any questions
so far
these are bought in this paper
yeah so our output size is proportional
to number of vertices so I'm talking
about solving a number of edges so what
is the result
surprisingly in fact it turns out that
we can get solve linear algorithm for
this problem despite and it's done
and so I'm going to show you we can get
actually very efficient some linear
algorithms for Delta plus one called
before that let me just say it our
algorithms are all going to be
randomized you are going to obtain a
delta plus one color and with high
probability if not you are going to
output that they failed so they are
never going to output the colouring
which is not visible and this is
important in this sub linear algorithms
because if I give you a color colouring
checking whether it was feasible or not
is actually probably impossible in this
model okay so now let's talk about a
result one is about sub linear time
algorithms we are going to have assume
some certain access to your graph this
is the sundered axis I can ask for a
degree of a vertex check whether a
vertex is neighbor to another one and
ask for a odd neighbor of a vertex right
or what we didn't know any sub linear
time algorithm for this problem and in
fact the faster the fastest algorithm we
knew for this problem is this a jewelled
greedy algorithm we showed that in fact
you can improve upon this algorithm and
get an end root n time algorithm for
doing Delta plus one color so if your
graph is not to a sports you can
actually color it faster than this
simple greedy algorithm that we saw
this algorithm has this nice property
that it's queries are going to be chosen
known adoptive lis so this is in some
sense the most simplest form of a sub
linear time algorithm you're just going
to decide on your queries beforehand ask
all of them from the graph look at them
and then just based on those queries
answer your question you don't need to
interact with the graph anymore the
running time is n root n we prove that
actually Omega and root n query to your
graph are also necessary even for
adoptive algorithm so this algorithm is
optimal streaming algorithms so we saw
in Michael stoixima streaming algorithms
I'm only going to focus on one pass
algorithms where the edges are coming in
the string previously again we didn't
know any sub linear space algorithm for
this problem but parallel to or what
people are also looking at this problem
they did this idea of let's relax the
problem let's look at an easier problem
of Delta plus a small off Delta coloring
and for that people come up with a semi
a streaming algorithm and later in the
talk I'll tell you actually avoid
allowing for this extra relaxation can
make the problem much easier our result
is that we you don't need this
relaxation we can actually also get a
single pass a streaming algorithm for
Delta plus one color and in video till
doughnut space
and for this problem this space is
nearly optimal because Omega s space is
necessary just to output the solution
and arresting Li this algorithm works
even if I have aged insertion and
deletion in my craft
this isn't somewhat surprising because
even for maximal matching that we have
good insertion only assuming algorithm
provably you cannot solve them in
dynamic graphics still Delta plus one
color and is solve about that and
finally for this NPC we didn't know such
an ostomy this is not a lower one
because we are giving the lower one
continues to hold the Omega and wrote on
time lower bounds so it's sorry let's
begin you'll always get n Delta because
if I give you neighbor queries you can
solve it with an Delta no ok if I do not
give your neighbour queries
I believe you can prove that and root n
is needed even when Delta is a smaller
but we cannot in this more generality we
cannot prove it because just simply not
true and Delta is a smaller you can
solve with an N Delta time always
it's okay NPC Alberta and I'm not going
to define the model but here basically
you take your graph your partition is
ages between multiple machines machines
can talk with each other and as long as
they do not send and receive more than
let's say order n come Oh dildo in
communication in each huh we knew a
bunch of result here there was a log log
Delta times log a star Rhonda and
algorithm paren memory for this Delta
plus 1 colors parallel to our work this
was improved to log a star and round and
for this easier problem of Delta plus
some extra colors constant run algorithm
vide Morris space right now our result
improve upon all of this we get constant
round an order and memory for this
problem and what is to me really
interesting is that if I make this
assumption of a public randomness so
suppose the machines have access to a
public set of random point then you can
solve this problem in exactly one round
if not basically the extra rounds are
only needed to share these random bits
maybe you need one or two more rounds
depending on the exact model let's just
skip this
so I've bombarded you with all these
different result I'm not going to talk
about them anymore the main result of
the paper is actually not any of this
but it's a structure result about Delta
plus 1 colors cheating will be useful in
other setting as well
what is that result it is very simple
looking a state now it says that look at
your graph G for each vertex sample log
in colors let's say you know uniformly
at random with repetition or without
repetition it doesn't matter that much
therefore each vertex is stored these
colors that you sample log n colors you
can use these sampled colors to color
the whole graph you don't need to have
access to any more colors let me share
an example with high probability say yes
all of our randomized algorithm are with
high prob this is my graph these are the
palettes next to each of them
maximum degree of this graph is five
here so I have six available colors to
attract X clearly if I use these
palettes I can color this graph what we
are claiming is that sample these
pallets each of them uniformly at random
to just get log n colors so you are
going to get something like this this
result says that with high probability
you can still color your graph
once again what was the result
comedy comes order log n colors with
perfect hair vertex and it's extremely
important yes independently per each
vertex not every graph is color were
with logon global collapse for each
vertex I'm sampling independently order
logon colors so why is such a result
useful event I want to argue that that
result is enough to get all these sub
linear algorithms immediately why look
at this type of algorithm look at your
graph sample this log in colors for each
vertex and then look at each edge in
your graph if the de least and the end
point of this H do not intersect just
delete that edge from your graph ok how
many colors remain in my craft well I
have how many edges remain in Minecraft
I had n Delta edges each of them one of
its end point sample log in colors each
of these colors appear on the other end
point with all the logon over Delta
so this graph has n log of square and
edges with high probability
but I only need this graph to get the
coloring I talked about so if I can list
color this graph use these palettes to
color this graph I get a delta plus 1
coloring of my original draw so this
says that basically look at your graph
you can on adoptive Lee reduce its end
Delta edges to only order n edges and
you are still able to color it with
Delta plus 1 colors example is that
suppose this was my sampled colors look
at this edge here for example I really
don't need this edge in my graph anymore
because this edge is never going to make
a problem for any colors that I choose
because those lists do not intersect so
I'm just going to drop it and all order
edge I'll get a sports or graph so this
is really just a sports if occasion
result for this problem so you know
there are sampling from Delta plus 1
colors each of them so so what I store
is also color were with Delta know star
is color with just two colors so yet so
a clique is a good example and I'm going
to show your void clique is so let's
talk about this problem now in this
result let me try to reformulate graph
coloring got some sort of an assignment
problem it's nothing fancy it's
basically just the same definition it's
going to just be a bit more helpful for
us let me start with an example of a
clique suppose I want to call her a Stix
click this is my click on six vertices
I'm going to map it to this graph which
I'm going to call a palette graph where
the size of my original graph forms the
left where this as the colors from the
right vertices and I put a complete
bipartite graph between de ok so it's to
finish and clear what does Delta plus
one color in means here it's just
finding a perfect matching in this
palette graph because the moment I find
a perfect matching I look at which color
is match to which vertex and go ahead
and color it the same way in my original
graph what does palette does
falsification means yes yes this is just
for the click ok so for the moment for
Killick what does Palais des Sports
education means when I'm working with a
clique it means that if I look at a
random sub graph of a boy part complete
bipartite graph or in other words if I
look at a random bipartite graph this
graph contains a perfect matching these
are statements are basically palletize
falsification for complete graphs is
equivalent to saying that a random
bipartite graph contains a perfect
matching good but we know these results
from random graph theory a random walk
or tight graph with degree log n has a
perfect matching with high probability
so this immediately proves the Pilatus
falsification for cliques
let me look at a slightly more general
graph suppose I had a clique I'd remove
a perfect matching from it so this is my
clique but I remove these edges
okay maximum degree now draw is drop for
Avon okay so I have to color this graph
with five colors instead of six again I
create the pallet graph Delta plus one
color in means finding a good soft graph
that will not define it formally but the
informally what is a good soft graph
well I do not have enough colors to
match every vertex to a unique color but
I do need to do that also some vertices
here can be matched to more than one
vertex okay what are those vertices
those vertices should not have an edge
between themselves in the original graph
so Delta plus 1 colors basically means
finding such a good soft graph in a in a
complete bipartite graph which is a
slightly lopsided what this palette has
falsification means for this type of
graph is that proving that random
bipartite graphs contain such good soft
graphs you took this vertex which the
top vertex on the right and you
connected it to the pair of vertices
that don't have a it should be an
independent set on the other side yeah
that's the formulation
so already this is again at some random
graph to your question and already here
it becomes a slightly harder than just
proving there exists a matching but this
is not also that hard to prove so now
what is the general formulation I give I
take my graph turn it into a pilot graph
and then in that graph I want to find a
sub graph which has this property every
vertex on the Left should be matched to
exactly one vertex on the line right
vertices on the right can be matched to
multiple vertices on the left as long as
these vertices form an independent set
in my original graph I agree this is
extremely convoluted definition and what
it works so so palette is versification
reduces to just solving some random
graph to your question what is good is
the dissonant reformulation is very
helpful when i'm talking about a
structure which look like a clique
clique - on edge Gillig - imagine ok
this formulation is terrible when I want
to talk about graphs which are very far
from being a Killick because then this
structure becomes so unpredictable that
basically I do not have any good handle
on that ok so let's introduce one more
idea so we are going to use this
formulation when I'm talking about
things which are like clique what if I
don't have something which is click
let's go to the other extreme case let's
I have a graph which is far from being a
Killick what is a good example I have a
low degree graph for example I assume
that I have a graph which all of its
vertices have degree smaller than Delta
over two ok I know this is cheating
because Delta is a maximum degree of my
graph so if you like add one vertex of
degree Delta just isolated somewhere
so okay so that formulation is hard but
how can we put proof palette as
falsification for this type of graphs
kill a man this is actually very easy
let me show you a procedure how do we
want to do this let me introduce up an
algorithm or a procedure for doing this
so look at your vertices for each vertex
sample a color uniformly at random from
1 to Delta plus 1 okay always just from
1 to Delta plus 1 nothing adoptive look
at this vertex if this color is never
sampling in the neighborhood of this
vertex and is not assigned to any of
them then assign that color to this
vertex ok and then repeat this process
over many iterations until all of your
vertices are color so many of you have
seen distributed algorithms lluvia style
algorithms for colouring before Delta
process one coloring this is not that
algorithm what is different
I'm always sampling from 1 to Delta plus
1
I'm never basically this algorithm
doesn't make any adoptive decision
always your sample from 1 to Delta plus
1 if I succeed in coloring does that
vertex I color it otherwise I remover
why is this good every vertex has degree
smaller than Delta over 2 I'm sampling
from Delta colors ok
so in my neighborhood the only Delta
over two of these colors are being used
each step I have probability 1/2 of
coloring this vertex ok so every vertex
will be colored with probability 1/2 in
each step I need log n iteration under
what does this thing have to do with
pallidus falsification but you can just
simulate this algorithm by the colors
with sampled for each vertex no I look
at the first color example don't assign
it before I could if not I'll go and it
says that you only need to go to log n
colors so this also proved this theorem
when my graph is sufficiently low degree
sufficient is just Delta over towards
just some constant factor away from that
okay so true this is special cases now
how does the general proof floor plan we
could handle clicks you could handle low
degree graphs let's into a product
between them what is the catch is that
I'll show you two different approach
each of them works for that specific
regime but they don't say anything about
the other one I told you this assignment
formulation is just very bad to talk
about lower Dietrich graphs and this
graph coloring algorithm I show you for
low degree graphs probably requires
Deltora iterations on a click so you
cannot just use that Pravda so it's
combined this ideas and our approach is
basically try to get our graph decompose
it into some cliques and some dense
parts on a sports part and try to
massage these ideas to work for that
to do that we're going to use this
brilliant result by harris noida and so
to actually give a network decomposition
for delta plus one color so this is
called HSS decomposition we have to
extend and modify it I'm just going to
show you the modification it's a very
small modification and I'll tell you
very modest find so what does this
decomposition says it says that look at
any graph and any parameter epsilon
between 0 & 1 you can partition vertices
of your graph as follows you are going
to have some vertices which we are going
to call a sports vertices these vertices
look at this blue vertex R such that
their neighborhood is epsilon far from
being a clique what does that mean it
means that if I look at all of its
neighbor this sub graph here is missing
epsilon fraction of edges of a clique ok
so immediately any low degree graph
and any low degree vertex is a sparse
vertex ok because you basically do not
have enough edges there to begin with
but even with this definition you may
have some vertices which have degree
equal to the maximum degree and already
still at sports because their neighbor
who doesn't have many edges so some of
my vertices are going to be as far as
$0.40 if i remove those vertices i'll
end up with these sub graphs in
collection of a bunch of soft graphs
that we are going to call them almost
clicks each almost clique is a structure
like this it's a sub graph on delt
roughly Delta vertices give or take
epsilon Delta any vertex in this sub
graph has at most epsilon Delta
neighbors outside ok and it has at most
epsilon Delta non neighbors inside let's
look at this shape these red vertices
form an almost clique because they are
basically click maybe some edges are
missing here and some of them have some
edges are
okay an HSS decomposition tell us that
any graph can be decomposed like this
basically the extension that I said is
just proving this bar Hsss decomposition
does not give you any lower bound on
size of this cliques and for their
purpose is completely okay if Killick
has size even Delta over two we
crucially need them to be really clicks
off sighs Delta with some minor
modification you get this
so what is or god or goddess to prove
this a statement if I have a graph if
for each vertex independently I sample
Augean colors I can still color all of
my graph with high probability how does
the proof look like well let's just fix
some of the one of this decomposition
for some tiny epsilon some constant is
enough okay one over x the sports where
t says we can handle them easily let's
just use bunch of these colors it's
login colors that we have and go ahead
and color them and this is the easy part
boy well these are not exactly low
degree where it is as law degree graphs
but they have essentially the same
structure and that simulation argument
actually works here it requires some
work but people especially deserve you
that community have a studied these type
of problems a lot okay and we can just
piggyback on those reso so this part is
just a simulation argument now the main
part is to try to color these structures
which look like cliques to do that we
are going to do as follows we are going
to look at a one click just assume that
you color everything else in your graph
it doesn't matter how your color done
just look at the vertices here I'm going
to claim that if I look at the color
sample by these vertices I can color
this part so I'm going to color this
almost click independently then I'm
going to look at the next one it doesn't
matter how it is colored outside even if
all of them are color we can color this
thing that stick and let me tell you
just some sort of an illustration
basically this is really all of the
proof is happening here and this
requires some generalization of that
assignment formulation I show so it's
just a quick example suppose this was my
original graph sum decomposition looks
like this blue vertices are sparse
vertices I have this almost click here
another almost click here
soiled decomposed minecraft like this
and let's say except that this part is
easy to call it I use half of the colors
I sampled for vertices in this palette
as falsification I color this point okay
the main part is how to color this graph
here and look like a structure like this
so I have this vertex let's look at the
assignment formulation it gives me this
palette graph now one quick thing this
is no more a bipartite complete
bipartite graph why because these
vertices have neighbors outside so for
example this guy here does not have an
edge to the blue vertex but this one
does not have an edge to the yellow
records the main technical result here
is that we are going to show that random
soft graphs of these type of palette
graphs actually contain those good soft
graphs that I define any vertex on left
has degree one anywhere clicks on droid
can be matched to arbitrary number of
vertices on the left as long as they
form an independent set in the original
graph okay so for example here a good
soft graph is just a matching basically
what if you almost are baby
yeah and that will make problem okay but
but what I told you is that we call her
one almost click we assume everything
else is colored
okay so it doesn't matter I'll color
this one even if that guy is neighbor to
it I'm going to just assume they have
colors and I'm going to color this one
if they don't have colors my life is
just going to be easier because I will
get less conflict well yeah definitely
we are going to have some almost clicks
which are neighbors to each other and so
this stands out to be some random graph
theory type question we are going to use
similar types of ideas and prove this
and let's believe it can be proven what
is the real challenge here it's just
that size of this almost glitz can be
very large it can be 1 plus epsilon
Delta so you have to match one vertex on
the right to many vertices on the left
and at the same time these graphs are
not complete bipartite graphs so you are
missing some edges also so it's really
not completely random bipartite graph
some subset of something which looks
like a clique and we have to prove that
it contains we have to prove that it
contains a good software and the reason
that we can prove it is that we put many
as lots of a structure on this palette
graph we're ensuring that it really
looks like a Killick adversarial or do
you use the technology often zoomed via
via zoom they are adverse area but there
is so much structure still we know how
many of them are being deleted ok so
every vertex for example we know have
the green something like 1 minus epsilon
Delta but yeah we are not going to
assume they're randomly
so we call her that part we do the same
strategy we call at this point we call
her the whole thing and this give us the
proof of this as falsification here let
me just very quickly tell you why we get
some linear algorithms here basically we
get this algorithm this is D sub linear
algorithm useful use palette as
fortification sample the graph sample
the colors to get this a sports avoid
graph let's call it conflict graph color
this graph find a list coloring of this
graph so what I have to do is to just
show you that X conflict graph can be
find in each model separately and that's
the only way we are going to treat this
different model separately in sublinear
time model we are going to give you an
algorithm that finds this finds this
conflict graph in n delta minimum of n
Delta and n square over Delta time and
queries which translates into and Rota
in a streaming is just trivial whenever
your edges are coming you can just
decide for your own whether it belongs
to the conflict graph or not and if yes
just a stone same way with MPC the
algorithm this way but there is a catch
here and you won't see what is the issue
this color is slow yes exactly so what
we've done is that we turned a linear
time solvable problem into an np-hard
problem the reason is that this palette
is falsification is an information
theoretic result not computational what
it means is that information
theoretically conflict graph is all we
need to acquire it but computationally
in these problems in general and peahen
maybe for a streaming and MPC it's not
that big deal but for some linear time
algorithm we can not get a solve linear
time algorithm from an np-hard so you
have to go back address this
it's basically translate into turning
this is information theoretic result
into an algorithmic result this means
that if you in addition to the conflict
graph you also give me that
decomposition or even some approximate
version of that then we design an
algorithm that can list color this graph
in an wrote on top and end route on time
here is actually the time needed to find
a perfect matching in a bipartite graph
with order n edges which we'll get from
Hopcroft core algorithm and this gives
us the end root n time algorithm solve
linear algorithm ops and then 1sf
remains because we need the
decomposition we have to design some
algorithms in this sub linear models
also to find a decomposition and this
part requires some work but this is a
straightforward we have lots of tools
and these models for doing this and now
this is the whole sub linear algorithms
now let me conclude quickly well we
obtained some linear algorithm for Delta
plus one color in these are the wrong
time or space all of these ones we
proved are optimal and we also proved
some lower want to contrast this problem
with seemingly very similar looking
problems
central tool here was this palette as
falsification tira
and let me mention some open questions
here one why I think yes this is my main
the most interesting question at this
point to me is to get deterministic
sublinear algorithms for this problem
and by that I really mean the streaming
for NPC I do not care that much and for
sub linear time I think it's easy to
prove that you can not do it
deterministic nee can we get a streaming
single pass preferably if not multi pass
even enter the smaller of one passes
algorithm for this problem but
determinists well it is interesting is
that it has some informal connections
also to getting deterministic
distributed algorithms for this problem
which is a longest-standing of one
problem also this family of maximal toy
problems that operates one coloring
maximal independence maximal matching
think these are really interested
problems that you need to understand
more these models so one question here
is that can be solved maximal
independent set in sublinear time or in
a multi pass system because we proved
that in single pass you cannot do this
and here there are actually known upper
ones there is a recent result that
employs a log log n pass algorithm but
there is no reason to assume that's
optimal
and finally this very general question
can be we've become very efficient in
sublinear algorithms to take a greedy
algorithm massage it and turn it into
sub linear algorithms the problem is
that these algorithms are typically
adoptive or multipass in the stream
think of matching problem getting better
than to approximation for matching some
of the main open question in graph is
streaming in two parts we can do it for
this reason that we can take a greedy
algorithm and implement it into us we
cannot do it in one pass so can we come
up with some non adoptive in sports
education instead instead of using
greedy algorithms to address this type
of problems that's all I wanted to say
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
so play attempt two questions I've got a
question so um if you know there's a
promise that the graph has a delta
coloring we're going to Delta minus one
coloring can apply your algorithms no no
it doesn't work for this reason that I
can show you a lower bond in all of
these models actually the Delta coloring
even if you know it's doable is hard in
these models so it's really all results
are very sensitive to Delta plus 1 and
Delta no no just no so Delta coding is
not np-hard you can do it it's the only
graphs which are not Delta color burr by
Brooks Terramar cliques and odd cycles
ok so it's not a computational problem
information theoretically you can prove
it
single pass the streaming algorithm if
it wants to Delta color a graph it
requires on my finest squares
Oh again no it won't work again even for
that ox so okay so I told you Delta plus
1 : has this very nice property that if
you fix color of any part of your graph
no matter how you did you can still
extend it to Delta plus 1 colors ok
nearly all of these results are based on
their using that implicitly but the
clipboard is explicitly using that that
the rest of it we just do not care how
we call our date okay well it's using
implicitly here that property is not
satisfied for Delta colony other
applications
- human other applications to other
problems or no I do not know I mean it
has applications to H colouring also
because you can reduce to Delta - one
edge coloring I guess some sort of
vertex coloring but it has lots of
application to Delta plus 1 colors in
congested click local model etc
- great so there are no more questions
and could speak a little more time and I
think the last session will start at